earlier this week I was forced to share
a cab to the Apollo Theater with our
associate producer Jordan shlonsky if
you're at all familiar with Jordan you
know how painful and experience that was
for me
thankfully I had my phone and one of our
sponsors Google Play to help me endure
this session take a look
Apollo Theater please Broadway was
originally named by the Dutch colony of
New Amsterdam we all stirred um back or
away was a naturally creative path
usually from heavy foot traffic or
perhaps animal why are we writing
together how did this what about you're
going in the same direction I know why
wouldn't we arrive together well you
were the moment answer that question we
wouldn't drag to the other because
you're such an irritating open Google
Play do something other than listen to
you I might play Angry Birds match right
the Broadway that was president of New
Amsterdam only went as high as vastra
okay which is typically called Wall
Street and in fact a reason it was
called balsa come on is because well a
wooden wall was present there to keep
out anyone north of that point I'm
playing Angry Birds match I'm not
looking at you I'm totally engaged in
this game that's a signal to most people
to maybe stop talking steam is utilities
supplied by con Edison New York City has
the highest quality tap waters in the
world the maximum theoretical
temperature of 212 degrees Fahrenheit
the American version of the book Asha is
a very dense spongy bread Duran Duran
had a quote in their song steam subway
which is technically incorrect I
considered the soundtrack to Footloose
to be a bit overrated I like the deep
cuts how many friends do you have
I mean real friends I'm not concerned
with friends means no friends
Jordan appears we are at the Apollo
Theater yes and I hope I never see you
again
now the marquee above us was originally
a person analog marquee and now of
course it's electronic would use an 8
hear me stay here
thanks for friends and Google Play for
helping us out there
[Applause]
you